madame monsieur bonsoir
voici les titres de l'actualité que nous
allons développer dans ce journal
les frappes de l'otan la nuit dernière
sur le centre de belgrade avec pour
cible les ministères de l'intérieur
serbe et yougoslave slobodan milosevic
affirme que rien ne sera plié le peuple
serbe
la guerre en yougoslavie a provoqué un
tremblement de perte démographique avec
290 1000 personnes chassées du kosovo la
tragédie des réfugiés à bout de force
6000 soldats de l'otan lors viendront en
aide
en albanie le canada de nos peuples
inuit un territoire dans le grand nord
25 mille personnes seront désormais
gouvernée par un premier ministre ou pas
c'est peu banal
et puis l'événement avec ou grand palais
une superbe exposition consacrée à
l'ancien épisode nansen inspire des gif
qui a construit la plupart des grandes
pyramides ouvrons ce journal avec les
opérations militaires de l'otan la nuit
dernière les bombardements ont touché le
coeur de belgrade avec pour cible les
ministères de l'intérieur serbe et
yougoslaves des frappes qui ont une
portée stratégique symbolique pour
autant ces opérations n'ont semble-t-il
pas toucher le moral des belgradois et
le premier d'entre eux slobodan
milosevic qui affirme que rien ne pourra
briser le peuple françois corner
deux images diffusées aujourd'hui par la
télévision de belgrade commençons par la
seconde filmé cet après midi dans la
capitale lugos lave sur un air de
folklore populaire serbe les belgradois
ont adapté les paroles traduisant leur
de thé nation a résisté
psychologiquement bombardements tout en
attisant le patriotisme national
ravva du désespoir d'un peuple difficile
d'interpréter cette réalité
flash-back la nuit dernière deux
immeubles sont en feu au coeur même de
belgrade celui du ministère fédéral de
l'intérieur et celui du quartier général
de la police serbe
deux symboles de la planification du
nettoyage ethnique au kosovo selon les
termes de l'otan sur place à belgrade le
témoignage de catherine monnot molik
pour les belgradois carlos et même une
partie de la ville qui n'avait pas été
entièrement détruite par les reds
allemand de 40 de la seconde guerre
mondiale qui a été touchée cette nuit
donc c'est tout un symbole mais dans le
sens du pire pour les pour les gens ici
et puis ils se disent aussi si longtemps
est capable de toucher la capitale c'est
qu'elles sont capables de tout qu ils
sont capables encore de toucher la
capitale belgrade qu'ils sont capables
de détruire tous les ponts du pays mais
pour autant cela n'a pas l'air
d'affecter en tout cas les gens refusent
de montrer que ça affecte le moral
deux cibles qualifié de stratégique par
l'alliance touchée par huit missiles de
croisière tomahawk tirés depuis les
navires de guerre américains croisant en
adriatique à 350 km de la capitale du
gosselaar sur le plan technique
l'opération semble parfaitement réussie
comme le prouvent ces images des deux
immeubles visés filmé au petit jour
c'est ce que les militaires appellent
une frappe chirurgicale il n'empêche que
le risque d'effets collatéraux étaient
ces normes
car à moins d'une centaine de mètres de
ce boulevard n'examine au chat se trouve
un hôpital abritant une importante
maternité cette maternité n'a subi aucun
dommage
mais par mesure de précaution les bébés
ont été descendus dans les caves se
tournant dans la guerre c'est frappe au
coeur de belgrade alors que l'otan
affirmait-il hier encore quelle
n'attaquerai ses cibles que dans le
cadre de la phase 3 de ses opérations de
bombardement a évidemment surpris les
belgradois comme cette infirmière que
nous allons entendre
personne ne croyait que nous pourrions
vivre cela dit elle nous nous préparions
bien sûr chaque jour à cet état de
guerre mais cette pluie nous avions du
mal à croire que cela nous arriverait
ces images illustrent bien en effet la
triste réalité d'une guerre qui même
s'il ne touche pas la population la
concerne chaque jour davantage
à tel point que les belgradois sont
aujourd'hui volontaire pour servir de
boucliers humains aux bombardements de
l'otan comme sur ce pont de belgrade la
nuit dernière les cibles civiles sont
exclus des objectifs de l'alliance mais
la destruction jeudi matin du pont de
novi sad a toutefois semer le doute et
on ignore ce soir si ces bombardements
ont fait des victimes
nous retrouvons en direct à bruxelles au
siège de l'otan jean-marc il use quelle
signification
peut-on donner bonsoir à ses
bombardements dans le centre de la
capitale yougoslave
apparemment il s'agit d'un tournant eh
bien disons ce n'est pas un tournant
décisif c'est un tournant mais c'est
surtout une nouvelle étape pour
l'intervention de l'otan en yougoslavie
et cela de deux manières sur le plan
militaire et sur le plan humanitaire
alors ce plan militaire manifestement
désormais belgrade n'est plus un
sanctuaire
mais ce n'est pas la population qui est
visé c'est bien là milices serbes
cette sorte de police et de gendarmerie
cent mille hommes avec des blindés qui
est le premier responsable du nettoyage
ethnique et en bosnie aujourd'hui au
kosovo une force dont le président
milosevic se sent beaucoup plus proche
que de l'armée régulière yougoslave
alors deuxième point sur plan
humanitaire les stratèges de l'otan se
rendent bien compte que leurs bombes
n'ont pas pu ou n'ont pas su arrêter le
flot des réfugiés expulsés du kosovo ils
doivent donc ils se doivent donc d'être
en première ligne en albanie avec les
considérables moyens dont il dispose
pour essayer de maîtriser ce désastre
humanitaire désormais à l'échelon d'une
région merci jean marc et 12 aux états
unis bill clinton affirme que le temps
fera payer le prix fort au président
serbe
il y a des moments où détourner les yeux
n'est plus une option notre mission est
difficile et dangereuse mais elle est
juste et nécessaire a ajouté le
président américain
le temps aujourd'hui à commencer de
déployer en albanie quelques 6000
soldats pour venir en aide
dans ce flot ininterrompu de femmes
d'enfants et de vieillards qui tente de
survivre
les chiffres sont dramatiques tout aussi
dramatique que les conditions de vie qu
affrontent ces réfugiés massés aux
frontières
selon l'alliance atlantique 290 1000
civils ont été jetés sur les routes ces
10 derniers jours cent trente mille
réfugiés vers l'albanie 70000 en
macédoine et 58 au monténégro à travers
les reportages de nos envoyés spéciaux
nous assistons aujourd'hui à une
véritable tragédie sous la pluie sans
force s'est réfugié au poste frontière
entre le kosovo et la macédoine vivent
ou plutôt survivent dans des conditions
d'extrême précarité les plus faibles
d'entre eux ne survivront pas plusieurs
personnes sont mortes d'épuisement
alors que sur place commencent à
s'organiser tant bien que mal d'une aide
d'urgence jérôme ni andry sera ou
d'attentes
les autorités macédoniennes ont bien du
mal à contrôler l'exode des habitants du
kosovo à chaque poste frontière attente
interminable chaque réfugié est
enregistrée il y a de l'autre côté une
colonne sur cinq à six kilomètres c'est
ce que nous avons entendu il doit y
avoir
vingt mille personnes auxquelles il faut
ajouter entre les deux postes frontières
environ 1500 personnes qui attendent
face à cette catastrophe humanitaire les
forces de l'otan ont changé leur fusil
d'épaulé
on prépare des repas chauds pour les
réfugiés les français font le don de
trois mille rations prévu pour une
journée le génie prépare des camps pour
recevoir les réfugiés
aujourd'hui il y assure la frontière à
10 km au nord un désastre humanitaire
nous avons dû ajouter à notre mission de
faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour
apporter notre aide
c'est le gouvernement macédonien qui
nous a demandé de le faire
nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés pour aider ces gens mais
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que cette
catastrophe humanitaire était prévisible
nous avons vu des événements dramatiques
au kosovo cette dernière
quinzaine ça a commencé avant le
bombardement quand le vérificateur
internationaux sont partis il est clair
que les forces yougoslaves ont redoublé
leurs offensives contre la guérilla
indépendantiste
il ya eu beaucoup de combats il est
inévitable que ça provoque un flux de
réfugiés à la frontière à 10 km la
solidarité albanaise ne désarment pas
une pluie froide à s'est abattue sur le
vallon de la détresse où sont entassées
quelques dix mille réfugiés épuisés
l'armée macédonienne de l'espace est ici
également qu'au compte gouttes
ces kosovars qui ont tout perdu
peuvent s'estimer heureux quand ils
survivent ils nous vous retrouvons en
direct jérôme nil les autorités
macédoniennes ont annoncé aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne pouvait plus faire face à cet
afflux de réfugiés
est-ce que vous m'entendez oui béatrice
ici effectivement macédoine c'est une
véritable catastrophe humanitaire qui se
poursuit il y a environ cent mille
réfugiés du kosovo le chiffre ici est
passé de 14 mille à cinq mille il ya
environ dix mille réfugiés qui vont
encore passer la nuit dans le froid
derrière moi ils sont complètement au
bout du rouleau ils n'ont plus du tout
le moral ils ne savent plus à quoi
croire alors il ya l'épuisement et puis
un problème psychologique qui fait qu'il
ya beaucoup de victimes
on pense qu'il y en a eu à peu près une
trentaine depuis 48 heures alors les
autorités macédoniennes peuvent sembler
inhumaines de retenir tous ces réfugiés
de ne laisser passer qu'au compte
gouttes mais il est vrai aussi qu ici il
ya un gros problème démographique et
politique qui se pose pour ce copier car
il ya déjà près de la moitié de la
population en macédoine qui est
maintenant albanaise avec cet afflux de
réfugiés et les autorités ne veulent pas
qu'une majorité de la population soit
albanaise et qu'il y ait des problèmes
comme il y en a en ce moment au kosovo
et tous ces réfugiés qui vont passer la
nuit ici pense aussi à ceux qui sont
restés là bas les albanais du kosovo qui
sont en proie à la répression des serbes
la haine provoquer et accentué en tout
cas par les bombardements et puis il y à
des combats qui se poursuivent entre les
forces serbes et la guérilla qui font
que bien sûr une grande partie de la
population civile car il y en a encore
des centaines de milliers de l'autre
côté se trouve dans le feu des combats
se trouve dans les poches de résistance
de la guérilla indépendantiste contre
l'armée serbe est dans une situation
souvent malheureusement encore beaucoup
plus dramatique que celle des réfugiés
qui sont arrivés ici
merci jérôme baugnies en albanie
maintenant l'aide humanitaire tente là
aussi progressivement de se mettre en
place avec d'énormes difficultés
d'organisation et d'acheminement les
réfugiés kosovars sont choqués épuisé
après plusieurs jours de marche souvent
dans des conditions difficiles comme le
monde ce reportage de benoît duquesne et
didier dames qui ont suivi à travers la
montagne la route de l'exil
les premiers que nous avons croisé
arrivé de nulle part un petit sentier
dans la montagne une voie étroite vers
la liberté que l'on emprunte en
chaussures de ville quand ce n'est pas
en fente ou des heures de marche dans la
nuit sous la pluie et parfois sous les
balles nous charles doit même ça fait
deux jours qu'on mange l1 avec sept
enfants de dix jours felice du lisier on
n'a plus rien à manger nous ont chassés
on n'a rien pu faire
ils ont chacun leur histoire mais tout
se ressemble
une litanie qui se répètent dit qu'on a
du mal à croire
- etam les sectes maintenant ma famille
est en sécurité mais d'autres familiales
ont tu leurs maisons brûlées se sont
fait tuer massacrer la nuit à aytré
laisser happer simplement quitter la
maison c'est notre pays
quelques heures de marche plutôt à la
frontière nous sommes au poste de chef
touche tous sont passés par l'un et lé
serbe domine le poste frontière et
l'ambiance est tendue
bon écoute et c'est dangereux ici
les serbes ont dit que s'ils voyaient
une caméra ici le tir et on ne peut pas
mettre en danger la vie des réfugiés
alors s'il vous plaît reculez car les
serbes sont susceptibles ils n'ont pas
aimé hier qu'on diffuse ces images qu'on
les films dans leur travail
sitôt la frontière passée à l'abri des
soldats serbes
c'est le soulagement et la colère on a
réussi à se sauver
on l'a échappé belle ça fait
vingt-quatre heures conte mars et ils
nous ont laissés dans un champ sous la
pluie sans nourriture comme des bêtes
ce ne sont pas des hommes sont des
cannibales mon enfant de trois ans je ne
sais pas comment il a survécu
comment il a pu endurer tout ça pour les
amener jusqu'à la frontière les serbes
leur font prendre des chemins escarpés à
cause des mines du style
la route sera coupée mais les kosovars
en doute il s'agirait plutôt pense-t-il
de les humilier un peu plus alors
imaginez la peur la souffrance les cris
des enfants et la fatigue des anciens
imaginez le froid et la pluie
essayez d'imaginer un exode aujourd'hui
gilbert des soûlards à 40 ans 3 vos
enfants qu'ils élevaient tranquillement
dans la ville de yako va avec son
salaire d'électricien hilbert de suva
n'a plus rien que la vie
no push to add mafia l' on ne peut pas
décrire par des mots ce qui se passe
dans la ville même les plus grands
poètes ne parviendrait pas comment dire
ce que notre ville a subi les massacres
dans les caves et quand ils quinze
vingts personnes brûlées dans leur
maison pour trouver écho aux familles
d'être inquiète c'est toute la région de
jack aux vacances chasse plus de cent
mille personnes
hilbert des choux la sauver sa famille
pour lui c'est l'essentiel
une ingénieure en albanie en direct de
cliquer benoît duquesne quel est ce soir
la situation sanitaire de ces réfugiés
ce que l'aide internationale d'urgence
commençait à arriver d'après ce que vous
avez pu voir absolument et dire que les
choses s'améliorent ça serait peut-être
un petit peu optimiste compte tenu des
images qu'on vient de voir mais qui se
passait je vous le dis le reportage à 3
heures environ de pistes d'ici mai dans
la région de louvain cela où nous vous
trouvons et bien les choses s'améliorent
un petit peu c'est vrai qu'on a commencé
à voir arriver aujourd'hui de l'aide
humanitaire des distributions de
l'ouverture c'est vrai qu'à la frontière
médecins du monde s'est installée que
caritas a déployé les temps qu'il ya
aussi un grand temps de tentes de la
sécurité civile italienne qui est en
train de s'installer qui devrait être
opérationnelle d'ici un jour ou deux
donc les choses vous le voyez s'améliore
et c'est vrai que l'annoncent de 3000 ou
6000 soldats de l'otan à venir avec
leurs bras leur aide et leur logistique
tout cela est bien sûr précieux ici car
le problème numéro un
ça reste bien sûr la logistique vous
savez que nous sommes à 10 12 heures de
camion de tirana donc il y à des camions
que la nourriture arrive très mal que la
route est encombrée
c'est pour cela que la stratégie du hsf
du hcr c'est toujours de faire partir
les gens le plus vite possible éviter
qu'ils restent ici bien sûr au rythme où
vont les choses les héros rythme ou
milosevic chasse les gens d'albanie de
ducos au pardon et bien c'est impossible
et donc il va falloir travailler des
deux côtés d'autant que même à terra
nada à tirana d'après ce qu'on nous dit
eh bien les structures
de logistique là aussi les camions le
corps les structures portuaires tout
cela ne suffit pas d'échangé de qui
arrive donc on attend beaucoup des ddt
et on espère pouvoir ainsi faire face à
cet afflux de personnes
on a dépassé aujourd'hui les deux cent
mille réfugiés dans la région
merci benoît l'allemagne pour sa part a
décidé de faire face à ce flot de
réfugiés en annonçant du mois qu'elle
allait accueillir des kosovars déportés
par l'armée serbe selon les termes
choisis par gerhard schröder au cours
d'une conférence de presse à bonn le
chancelier allemand appelle les autres
états de l'union européenne à prendre en
charge un certain nombre de ces réfugiés
en albanie l'armée de libération du
kosovo lucet car recrute des volontaires
des centaines d'entre eux venus de
différents coins de l'europe se sont
retrouvés près de dur est bien décidé à
aller se battre contre les troupes
serbes désir le temps en craignant une
déstabilisation de toute la région
parlait de l'éventualité d'un coup
d'état au monténégro cet état
démocratique considéré comme le petit
frère is the slave seraient repris en
main par slobodan milosevic et ce soir
la france met en garde contre toute
tentative de déstabilisation bernard
lebrun le lâchons pas le kosovo
un slogan un parti celui de la serbie
pourtant cette impressionnante
manifestation promis aux sévices ne se
déroule pas à belgrade
mais à podgorica la capitale du
monténégro cette petite république de
l'ex yougoslavie la moins peuplée six
cent mille habitants est la plus pauvre
et la dernière à faire partie de la
fédération yougoslave
à ce titre elle accueille sur ses terres
le deuxième corps d'armée du pays
pour cette raison le monténégro a aussi
été la cible des bombardements des
forces de l'otan ces derniers jours
seulement voilà milo djukanovic own
président progressistes et démocrates a
refusé de s'aligner sur belgrade en
rejetant l'état de guerre de la
yougoslavie ont clamé par le seul ce
bonhomme milosevic
ne reconnaissons pas l'état de guerre le
gouvernement dit aux gens nous vous
mobilisant à vos places de travail donc
la priorité c'est la mobilisation civile
est pas la mobilisation militaire
conséquence les manifestations se
multiplient en serbie comme ici hier à
l'escaut va pour dénoncer les prêtres
d'unités naissance et le ton de monter
c'est pour ceux qui refusent d'être
mobilisés pour défendre la patrie et se
battre au cochon milosevic de son côté
s'est empressé cette semaine de remanier
l'état majeur de la deuxième armée
affectant au monténégro des fidèle
d'entre les fidèles et alimentant ainsi
la rumeur d'un coup d'état
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y
adeux de pouvoir qui s'affrontent au
monténégro qui sont parallèles dont le
pouvoir civil qui est donc le
gouvernement légal et légale du
monténégro de la république du
monténégro et donc le pouvoir
d'exception qui est le pouvoir militaire
suite à le décret d'état d'urgence qui a
été décrétée par le président de la
fédération
l'affrontement se limite pour l'instant
aux menaces verbales mais la communauté
internationale se déclare très préoccupé
unique façade maritime de ce qu'il reste
de la yougoslavie
elle sait l'importance stratégique que
représente le monténégro pour belgrade
et l'italie annoncé cet après midi 15 g8
pourrait se réunir la semaine prochaine
pour discuter du conflit yougoslave
je vous propose maintenant de suivre à
travers les éditions de la télévision
serbe la façon dont les journalistes ont
rendu compte aujourd'hui par exemple des
informations concernant le conflit en
ligue 1 la vie à l'évidence le modèle
milosevic sait mieux que personne manier
cet outil de communication valérie
fournier
invariablement quoi qu'il arrive la
grand-messe de 19h30 de la télévision
serbe commence avec l'image de leur
leader
slobodan milosevic calme entouré des
hommes forts du pays
la journaliste li un communiqué sur des
images muettes
elle évoque je cite le vandalisme
invraisemblable des forces de l'otan et
annonce avec conviction le retour des
réfugiés albanais au kosovo qui je sais
toujours a lieu comme prévu d'ailleurs
les téléspectateurs serbe n'auront
jamais la preuve par l'image de ces
allégations sun ces diapositives
illustre ce qui se passe à leurs
frontières
en revanche le concert de soutien à
skopje hier en macédoine est largement
montré et le correspondant par just hits
d'union contre le fascisme mais comme
dans chaque édition de la journée le
premier reportage en images évoquent les
frappes de l'otan 7 me sur belgrade
beaucoup d'interviews aux discours
invariable dans les qualificatifs et les
comparaisons en avril 1941 les nazis de
hitler ont bombardé belgrade
et voilà en 1999 encore en avril ce sont
les néonazis de culte et de l'otan qui
bombarde à nouveau belgrade
la présentatrice ajoutera que l'otan a
bien visé des cibles civiles
les ministères je cite n'ont été
atteints que par inadvertance une
télévision serbe qui n'a pas manqué de
saluer les performances de sky news et
de cnn deux chaînes qui ont je cite
glorifiant direct la force sanguinaire
de l'otan quant à bill clinton a
qualifié de fureur américain maniaque
sexuel tard et il n'est uniquement
montré qu'en compagnie de monica
levinsky le navire russe qui a quitté
hier le port de sébastopol en ukraine
est arrivé à istanbul notamment le
passage du bosphore
il fait route vers l'adriatique c'est le
premier bâtiment de guerre d'une flotte
qui pourrait compter six autres navires
la grèce a refusé d'accueillir d'urgence
vingt mille réfugiés adressé une fin de
non-recevoir au hcr depuis le début du
conflit la grèce a toujours manifesté
son hostilité aux frappes de l'otan
hier à salonique plus de quinze mille
personnes ont assisté à un concert de
solidarité avec les yougoslaves frappés
par les bombardements
le cinéaste grec theo angelopoulos e
palme d'or l'année dernière à cannes et
le compositeur mikis theodorakis ont
apporté leur soutien à ce concert
d'autres concerts anti otan se sont
déroulées dans différentes villes du
pays
la croix rouge française fait appel à la
solidarité et demandent des colis de
vivres pour les réfugiés du kosovo
c'est le ministère des affaires
étrangères qui prendra en charge
l'acheminement de ces colis l'exemple de
la mobilisation à salon de provence
jacques cardoze réunion la modeste
contribution la voici un colis pour une
famille de réfugiés riz pâtes sucre
sardines légumes fruits secs et savon de
marseille
à peine 50 francs pour tenter de leur
venir en aide faites vos courses
une opération qui a débuté ce matin
devant certains hypermarchés ou
supermarchés et qui se généralisera dès
mardi dans 1200 comités locaux croix
rouge de france
on va avoir une première vague de
denrées ce soir que nous allons déjà
trié et préparer un premier
conditionnement ensuite à partir de
mercredi donc la poste nous fournira des
colis des colis tiff
que nous rangerons ce que nous rangerons
palettes et les palettes sur un cheminée
par la poste et sont ensuite transportés
par le big air france est redistribué
été redistribués sur place la collecte
doit permettre l'arrivée des premières
d'henri la semaine prochaine la croix
rouge prévoit d'échelonner les envoie au
moins jusqu'au 18 avril
une initiative qui semble plutôt bien
accueillie dans les bouches du rhône
c'est tout à fait normal d'aider les
populations qui sont en difficulté ce
sont des êtres humains comme nous et je
trouve que c'est normal de les aider
voilà moi j'adore croix de l'onu 9h pas
na li 7 3 transférer les pauvres gfc
très anti jeu les données madame
volontiers c'est quand on voit c'est la
télé c'est scandaleux et certains
voudraient même que la france aille plus
loin dans son aide humanitaire tant est
qu'on puisse accueillir les gens ici
aussi je crois dans les maisons oui
quand on fait quelque chose il faut
aller jusqu'au bout
la croix rouge peut compter sur une
france généreuse bien décidé à aider
tant que possible les réfugiés du kosovo
et à partir de demain france télévisions
diffusera des spots pour la croix rouge
française afin d'aider les réfugiés du
kosovo
voici d'ores et déjà l'adresse postale
pour collecter vos chèques croix rouge
française kosovo bp 300 75008 paris
s'est donc affiché sur votre écran croix
rouge française kosovo bp 300 75008
paris
en fin d'après midi à paris environ 150
étudiants albanais et membre du comité
kosovo se sont rassemblées place de la
sorbonne
une manifestation qui dans un premier
temps avait été interdite
voilà donc cette manifestation plutôt ce
rassemblement de 150 étudiants albanais
du kosovo
voyons maintenant comment l'opinion
publique française réagit à la situation
yougoslavie de sondage à sortir de ma
pour ifop ouest france 58% des français
approuvent l'engagement militaire de la
france selon ipsos journal du dimanche
165 % à y être favorables et 32 % se
disent opposées quant à la question de
l'éventualité d'une intervention
terrestre au kosovo une majorité de
français sont pour 55% pour ifop ouest
de france et 58% pour ipsos journal du
dimanche
ils sont 39 % et 35 % à y être opposés
enfin le conflit en yougoslavie au
centre des préoccupations de jean paul
ii le saint père lors du chemin de croix
du vendredi saint
s'est exprimé sur la situation dans les
balkans carlu nos draps des dizaines de
milliers de pèlerins étaient rassemblés
hier soir à rome pour la procession du
vendredi saint à la lumière des
flambeaux le pape jean paul ii a conduit
le chemin de croix quatorze de stations
pour symboliser la marche du christ
jusqu'à la colline du golgotha où il a
été crucifié affaibli après une
opération du fémur à 60 18 ans le
souverain pontife à porter comme chaque
année une croix de trois kilos et demi
en début et en plantations le regard
fixe il s'est ensuite adressé à la foule
rassemblée autour du colisée abandonnant
l'homélie prévu il a invoqué le seigneur
afin je cite que nous ne perdions pas le
courage l'audace de l'espérance devant
les drames de l'humanité
en effet le vatican ne désespère pas
d'obtenir une réponse au message
personnel que le souverain pontife
adressée jeudi à le temps et où
président clinton dans l'espoir d'une
solution au kosovo
il propose une trêve pascale entre le 4
et le 11 avril
demain dans son message solennel brille
et orbi l'appel pour être laissée plus
directement encore aux pays concernés
les propos du pape seront relayées
partout dans le monde par la télévision
sauf en yougoslavie un fluide politique
française avec en campagne pour les
européennes ne françois bayrou et
philippe douste-blazy là aussi les
dirigeants du dev sont revenus sur la
situation au kosovo jean baptiste près
dalli jean-paul miotto
pas de doute qu'il y à bien une campagne
électorale pour les européennes à tarbes
françois bayrou la tête de liste udf a
choisi la proximité jusqu'à parler berne
pour l'instant sur le marché de tarbes
comme ailleurs il s'agit surtout de
rodez les thèmes et les discours
pourtant l'europe l'actualité le kosovo
ont rattrapé la campagne qui commence
vous cachez pas ce que révèlent nos
sources c'est que l'europe n'a pas la
défense qu'elle mériterait
elle n'a pas l'armée les moyens de
défense ou de sécurité qui devraient
être les siens et même devant des
agriculteurs du gers avant le débat
obligé sur la réforme de la politique
agricole commune
françois bayrou parle encore du kosovo
ce que nous faisons pour les européennes
il a décidé de faire cavalier seul
histoire de se démarquer du rpr et de
fizi séguin histoire surtout de marquer
sur le terrain comme on dit qu'à droite
les seuls vrais européens sont à l'udf
à quelque 100 jours de l'élection les
premiers meetings sont l'occasion de
reprendre via l'actualité le classique
plaidoyer centriste en faveur de
l'europe l'euro et fait l europe n est
pas faite au kosovo c'est pas l'europe
qui s'est exprimé c'est les états unis
et la multitude la poussière des états
européens 18,1 et 18
c'est à dire un tout seul qui commande
et les autres qui suivent françois
bayrou compte sur sa première campagne
nationale en solo pour affirmer sa place
dans l'opposition
cela vaut pour l'élection du 13 juin
prochain et pour l'être il ya 100
journée c'est l'euro un anniversaire
marqué par une semaine chaotique puisque
après un très bon départ en janvier la
valeur de l'euro s'est effrité face au
dollar notamment à cause de la crise au
kosovo
jean-paul chapelle marcel martin il y a
trois mois
l'euro était inaugurée dans l'euphorie
des marchés financiers la seule question
était alors jusqu'où va-t-il monter
trois mois plus tard c'est la déception
l'euro a perdu 10% de sa valeur par
rapport au dollar avant les événements
du kosovo on avait déjà une forte
croissance américaine face à une
économie européenne qui se porter et qui
se porte encore moyennement et la guerre
au kosovo renforce cet effet là en ce
sens qu'elle a tendance à renforcer le
rôle de valeur refuge du dollar
il faudra encore du temps pour que
l'euro atteigne ce statut de valeur
refuge
un nouvel étalon concurrents du dollar
c'est le rêve du gouverneur de la banque
centrale
pour lui la monnaie européenne n'est ni
forte ni faible et stable
cet avis est normal et si le faire 10%
depuis le 1er janvier par rapport au
dollar la veille gagné 10% là deux mois
avant le 1er janvier
en attendant la faiblesse relative de
l'euro rend les produits européens moins
cher et donc plus compétitif on a besoin
d'un euro qui ne soit pas trop fort afin
que nos entreprises puissent aussi
exporté en dehors de la zone euro je
pense donc on est globalement dans une
situation satisfaisante fort ou faible
l'euro a surtout maintenant l'avantagé
d'exister s'ils permettent en prime une
baisse des taux d'intérêt il donnera
alors un coup de pouce à la croissance
européenne
nous vous le disions cette semaine le
canada a finalement créé un territoire
dans le grand nord qui sera gouverné par
le peuple inuit le premier ministre à 34
ans c'est donc le premier chef de
gouvernement de ce territoire de 25000
habitants
son histoire est peu banale puisque cet
homme était autrefois les coliques
il a même fait de la prison dominique
derda sa victoire c'est d'abord une
victoire sur lui-même et c'est pour cela
qu'ils ont élu pour l'espoir qu'il
incarne celui de tout un peuple
au local hic est le premier chef de
gouvernement du nunavut ce territoire qu
après plus de vingt ans de négociations
le canada a fini par céder aux inuits du
grand nord
je suis très heureux oui très heureux
à 34 ans il a l'humilité de ceux qui
reviennent de loin
et tous ici le savent avant d'être
avocat puis premier ministre pour le
khalife fut longtemps alcoolique il fit
même un séjour en prison pour avoir
cambriolé une boutique et volé quelques
bouteilles ailleurs sous d'autres
latitudes avec un tel passé difficile de
s'imaginer un avenir en politique mais
pas à iqaluit 8 où rares sont les
familles épargné par l'alcool
les inuits est à dire il faut juger un
homme non pas pour ce qu'il fut mais
pour ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
ceux qui connaissaient son histoire ce
qui dans leur famille avaient les mêmes
problèmes ils ont été séduits élan
soutenu
ils se sont dit quelqu'un qui parvient à
surmonter sa part gamme va sans doute à
se remonter beaucoup d'autres choses
encore d'autres obstacles
alors oui pour beaucoup de gens ça a
plaidé en sa faveur
loin des tentations et des pièges du
monde moderne
c'est dans ses racines ses souvenirs en
noir et blanc d'une époque à jamais
révolue que paulo khaliq peu à peu a
puisé la force et le courage de vaincre
ses démons intérieurs
il n'y avait dans le passé ni prison ni
alcool
c'est ce qui m'a aidé à remettre de
l'ordre dans ma vie ça a été pour moi un
exemple est gelée suivi new star je n'ai
plus besoin d'alcool pour me sentir bien
pas plus que mes ancêtres n'avaient
besoin d'alcool question vivre comme ils
vivaient
et c'est sur les mêmes bases comme on
façonne un igloo qu'il a bâti son projet
politique en s'appuyant sur l'expérience
des anciens ont confiant à chacun un
rôle à sa mesure en laissant à la
communauté le soin de décider quel
serait le chemin suivre vos localités
espère que la naissance de ce nouveau
territoire soit pour les habitants du
nunavut
une renaissance personne évidemment et
surtout pas ses enfants ne songerait à
vivre comme vivait à l'orage cette femme
de 64 ans les histoires qu'elle raconte
dans leur langue lino qui toutes ont le
goût lointain est parfois étrange d'un
paradis perdu pour relever les défis qui
attendent le nunavut le logement la
justice l'éducation la santé il faudra
sans doute plus que ses recettes
millénaire et la sagesse des vieillards
alors avant chaque réunion de la
nouvelle assemblée à la lumière d'une
lampe à l'huile de phoque le tambour et
les chants invite les esprits à guider
les travaux des élus comme ils ont su
guider jusque là les pas d'un ex
alcoolique devenu premier ministre
il y est
retour en france vous étiez nombreux à
prendre la route des départs pour ce
long week-end de pascal 160 km de
bouchons total beaucoup de
ralentissements notamment région
rhône-alpes et d'accrochages due à la
pluie dans plusieurs grandes villes de
france
voici donc les images des
ralentissements dans plusieurs grandes
villes de france à toulouse à lille à
lyon et à paris des milliers de motards
manifestaient aujourd'hui 2500 d'entre
eux ont traversé la capitale pour
protester contre la loi gayssot avec
notamment la création d'un délit de
grande vitesse laurent bay
à paris la préfecture de police hurlent
à comptait 2500 un véritable concert de
klaxons par lequel ces motards entendent
protester contre le projet de loi de
jean claude gayssot le ministre des
transports qui crée notamment un délit
de grande vitesse dans la capitale comme
partout ailleurs en france aujourd'hui
leur message était simple les motards ne
sont pas les responsables de
l'insécurité routière et de ses huit
mille quatre cents morts en 98 il est
donc injuste qu'ils soient les premiers
pénalisés en mélangeant que la sécurité
est pratiquement
parce que le banditisme c'est vrai qu'il
faut pas faire n'importe quoi mais il
faut aussi que les oies les doigts soit
adaptée et plutôt que de répression il
voudrait qu'on parle de prévention ça
veut dire mieux former les conducteurs
mais aussi tout simplement mieux
entretenir les routes pour demande c'est
plutôt un meilleur entretien des
infrastructures débloquer des fonds pour
l'entretien des infrastructures plutôt
que pour dire l'achat de nouveaux radars
pour demande aussi c'est une meilleure
formation dès le plus jeune âge dans les
écoles et tous que les jeunes soient
informés dès le plus jeune âge
quand la loi passera les contrôles vont
augmenter ainsi que les crédits et les
effectifs de gendarmerie
mais les motards en colère ont promis de
manifester à nouveau
il refuse de jouer les boucs émissaires
le mondial de la maquette et du modèle
réduit ouvre ses portes aujourd'hui à la
porte de versailles le modélisme compte
trois millions de passionnés
dominique barrau chez jean mais vous
sert en ont rencontré quelques-uns
d'abord chargé le charbon jusqu'à la
gueule qui a un briquet le mini monstres
de fonte est prêt à cracher la vapeur
105 cm 110 kg la bête humaine modèle
réduit et ça roule les 40 membres de ce
club de la région parisienne passait la
moitié de leur week end à construire
leurs chevaux vapeur et l'autre moitié à
les conduire les adultes font joujou
et puis quand j'avais l'âge de m'amuser
je vais pas l'occasion de faire tout ça
non mais je me rends compte maintenant
ici les as et leurs drôles de machines
ce biplan de la guerre de 14 reprend du
service en tout pacifisme
autour de l'hélico on fixe les pales
l'essence au compte-gouttes décollage
ils essaient quand on n'est pas d'abord
c'est dur
on doit interpréter une sensation
visuelle en fait
tandis que quand on est dans l'appareil
on est assis on ressent cette vibration
coton pilote dans l'avion il ya des
coûts réels ou
biot avec ses fesses en isme la balle à
ans qui note avec sa vue à 12 ans
stéphane est champion de france
d'aéromodélisme
pour ce passionné de modèles réduits il
n'y a ni âge ni limite ses plaisirs on
satisfait dans la la réduction des
passions et des envies qu'on ne pourrait
pas satisfaire dans la réalité c'est
bien évident
les mordus de la maquette n'hésitent pas
à passer des milliers d'heures à
fignoler la cambrure d'une coque ou
fixez un gréement dans le monde du
modèle réduit le temps aux seuls prend
des proportions démesurées
en tennis la france april avantage sur
les pays bas en coupe davis le double
cédric pioline guillaume raoux s'est
imposé face aux hollandais
cet après midi au terme d'un match
marathon christelle bertrand blaise
grenet plus de quatre heures a bataillé
pour ramener un point qui coûte cher
cinq sets deux tie-breaks et une
victoire face à une des meilleurs
équipes de double monde un set partout 3
jeux partout guillaume raoux s'emballe
le match les français ont été pas mal
secours cédric pioline est le plus
surprenant c'est son premier double en
coupe davis
et c'est lui qui a été le plus constant
il faut dire que raoult cela donner de
bons conseils
sur le papier les choses sont toujours
plus simple
pioline appliquent les consignes les
deux hommes ont gagné le troisième set
au tie break
la tension monte au fil des points
raul c pioline passe à côté d'une balle
de match la quatrième manche et pour la
hollande dernier set
quitte ou double raul cepsa line font la
course en tête score final 6 4 5 7 7 6 7
6 2 en faisant jouer pioline faut
regarder le bon choix l'écart fait un
grand match on savait guillaume capable
de bien jouer en coupe davis mais cédric
c'est du nouveau donc c'est ça moi ça
met du baume au coeur
toutes les manières nous ont gagné ils
sont allés chercher je pas très loin au
fond d'eux mêmes
les ressources pour s'imposer face à une
bonne équipe de hollande franchement
c'est une grande victoire aujourd'hui
qui j'espère nous amènera à qualifier la
france demain pour avoir besoin de
l'atrium du talent
et ça c'est pas si mal que ça photo la
france mes deux voisins demain le
premier match opposera pioline à
krajcsak forget va encore y laisser des
hommes les amoureux de la glisse extrême
se sont donné rendez-vous à vars pendant
une semaine ils viennent du monde entier
l'occasion de découvrir une discipline
le freeride le ski hors-piste alexandre
kara nathalie gallet loin des pistes au
coeur de la neige deux hommes observent
la montagne stéphanie gehrlein sont des
free riders autrement dit des amoureux
du hors piste demain c'est la finale de
la compétition dans laquelle ils sont
engagés
regarde le haut en reprenant de près mal
de pierres en offrons des cours n'est
sorti du couloir après ces mille c'est
super le freeride est l'une des
disciplines de la nouvelle crise
l'esprit en est simple s'offrir le
maximum de sensations là où l'homme n'a
pas encore dompter la nature
je respecte tout à fait le la
philosophie en tous les cas général de
tous les freeriders tous les skieurs qui
est la liberté avant tout et et la
manière de skier en fait c'est notre
manière de vivre aussi dans la vie de
tous les jours j'aborde ça d'une façon
vraiment j'y vais pour me faire plaisir
je les pende que je vais chercher ce
soit un saut au poids qu'une caméra
photographes ou que ce soit une course
le jeu parce que je cherche avant tout
c'est le plaisir
le free ride c'est l'aboutissement d'un
parcours de glisseur sur ces pentes
vertigineuses
il n'y a nulle place pour
l'improvisation
je crois que c'est important de ne pas
nous faire passer non plus pour des
barjots qui sautant des bardes rocher ou
sans savoir où on va et au petit bonheur
la chance c'est pas du tout ça je crois
que c'est des années et des années et
des années de pratique et ça arrive ça
vient pas au hasard hein
en vérité peu importe la compétition
l'essentiel est ailleurs se retrouver
semaine après semaine sur toutes les
neiges du monde pour glisser ensemble
dans un bonheur infini
cette superbe exposition grand palais
qui s'ouvrira dans quelques jours un
événement pour la première fois des
pièces inédites datant de l'ancien
empire d'égypte seront présentés gérard
dalmaz michel levasseur point culminant
de leur mission humaine au service de
lahm
les sentinelles de pierre et leurs
gardiens ont vaincu le temps depuis
l'ancien empire cinq siècles de création
dans le visage du pharaon kephren qui
surgit enfin de l'ombre grâce à cette
exposition première sur cette période de
l'egypte à côté des pyramides sens est à
ce jour
l'art est déjà à son âge mûr avec le
sourire de la sérénité
il constitue déjà le modèle pour les 3
millions qui suivent
exemple ce champ sont liées à deux âges
de sa vie
les artistes au royaume ne s'intéresse
pas qu'au statut sales and hell qu'il
fallait voir de face la vie quotidienne
est rendu d'une manière touchant les
créateurs sculpte l'affection de sa
famille
avec le fils portant encore l'emblème de
l'enfance la tresse sont aux côtés de
ted est rarissime dans l'histoire de
l'art la tendresse des couples souvent
cette incroyable avec l'époux à taille
égale mieux parfois mari et femme sont
en place
figurez vous que l'on se penche aussi
sur le menu artisans bronzé par le grand
air ou encore le petit personnel
les modèles c'est à dire les serviteurs
des tombeaux potier harpiste boulangère
bouchée des métiers taillé dans le
calcaire qui rappelait sa vie terrestre
au défunt parti pour l'au delà
quant aux animaux ils ne sont pas
oubliés les a ni s'ils ne sont pas des
mal aimés ou encore la du attendrissant
de la vache à son veau aucun rythme
aucune civilisation nature si loin dans
sa lutte contre la mort
la preuve l'egypte antique est toujours
jeune il ya même une étincelle dans son
regard sur l'horizon de l'immortalité
avant de refermer ce journal ces
quelques images des 50 ans de paris
match une émission spéciale de michel
drucker que vous retrouverez dans
quelques instants
un plateau exceptionnel avec notamment
des hommes politiques et aux politiques
qui ont marqué cette période
ensemble sur le même plateau quatre
anciens premiers ministres
et puis toute une pléiade de
personnalités
oui c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres
les frappes de l'otan la nuit dernière
sur le centre de belgrade avec pour
cible les ministères de l'intérieur
serbe et cela slobodan milosevic affirme
que rien ne fera plier le peuple serbe
et puis on a pris un instant que les
sirènes ont retenti à 20 heures à
belgrade la guerre en yougoslavie a
provoqué un tremblement de terre
démographique avec 290 1000 personnes ça
c'est du kosovo depuis le début de
l'opération de l'alliance
la tragédie des réfugiés à bout de
souffle 6000 soldats de l'otan leur
viendront en aide
en albanie dans un instant la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h55 donc les années
match présentée par michel drucker je
vous retrouve de mal dès 13 heures je
vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
m